president biden has a solution to
america's gas price at crisis blame
everyone but himself after ordering the
release of one million barrels of oil
per day from the strategic reserve the
president obsessing over putin putin's
war is imposing the cost on america and
our allies
and democracies around the world the
start of this year gas was about three
dollars and thirty cents a gallon
today it's about average in 420 422 is
higher in many states the reason for
that
is because of putin's war i'm going to
continue to use every tool at my
disposal to protect you from putin's
price hike
it's not time for politics
and when he wasn't pushing his putin
price hike talking point the president
was busy demonizing american oil
companies
but some companies have been pretty
blunt
they don't want to increase supply
because putin's price hike means higher
profits this is the time
not the time to sit on record profits
it's time to step up for the good of
your country the good of the world to
invest in immediate production that we
need to respond to vladimir putin
but there's a huge problem for biden
americans know exactly who to blame the
majority 38 percent fault biden and only
6 blame russia's invasion of ukraine
all right well it seems greg that the
americans really understand what's going
on here that they're very intuitive and
that biden can push as much as he wants
but is it going to work no you know what
i think he assumes everybody is as
forgetful as he is we know what
inflation was like before the war it was
soaring i'm sure the war didn't help it
but it was on its way up way way before
uh putin went into ukraine um but the
thing that's that ticks me off about
this is the constant refrain of the
putin price hike means that the white
house is more concerned and spends more
time with creating handy slogans than
actually handling the problem of
inflation the nature of inflation
doesn't really affect them because it's
not a problem when you're in power or
you're wealthy but the messaging is we
talked about this yesterday was uh
yamiche alcindor
thank you very much uh said it's a
messaging problem right that's all it is
it it it it's everything you need to
hear about the left is that nothing is a
problem until it threatens your
political power inflation hurts the the
poor
but it's a problem only if it costs you
votes crime hurts the poor and
minorities but it's only really a
problem if it's going to cost you an
election so all of this all what you're
seeing right now it's not about morality
it's about messaging and that's
disgusting because we could have sought
we if we he keeps saying it's all about
everybody we should stop talking about
politics
about florida dude you're the only
person that's politicizing this no one
else is i don't no one cares about the
messaging they just want to get their
their bread and milk down yeah and they
want to get off that 5200
tax hike basically that is inflation but
dana do they have time to turn this
around before the midterms no i here's
another one of dana's rules i know you
like those um when you hear that there's
a communications problem anywhere with
the company or at the white house
wherever it might be 99 of the time it's
not it's a fact problem and it's very
frustrating to the communicators because
if you fix the facts if you had better
policy then you fix your pr problem
that's the way it works just this week
president biden called for 11 new taxes
on american energy okay so
putin's price hike you can't get more of
a price hike than doing like putting
more taxes on energy and gas so this is
another pr move that will actually
exacerbate the pr problem and the fact
problem that they're trying to fix the
other thing that really bothers me and i
would like a permission to use an
analogy permission granted so i'm always
fascinated by the strategic petroleum
reserve tapping it and then the white
house trying to say that that's an
accomplishment that's like trying to get
credit for paying off your credit card
bill by taking out a loan
and there's no plan to replace it i'll
just say one other thing in 2020 the
republicans put forward a plan under
president trump to refill the strategic
petroleum reserve because gas prices
were at record the oil prices were at
record lows and chuck schumer the senate
democratic leader at the time said
he was proud to be the one to kill it
okay so now they're announcing
to take a million barrels out of debt we
use 25 million barrels or i'm sorry it's
more than that i don't have the number
here but it's a drop in the bucket and
they have they've announced no plan to
refill it it's supposed to be for
emergencies well you know with regard to
that jesse i mean they're talking about
releasing a million barrels a day which
apparently is 1.3 million barrels below
where we were when trump was in office
and in november when we tapped the
reserve and then again in march when we
tapped the reserve gas prices went down
for a minute and then they flew up again
what good does it do here's how dumb
chuck schumer is when trump wanted to
restock the reserves
oil was at 24 a barrel right right that
would have been the best time to restock
the stockpile and now so he's going to
shed about a third of the stockpile 180
million out of 560 million barrels
that's the stockpile
we're letting go a third of the
stockpile
he someone's going to have to replenish
that it's never going back down to 24 in
the next couple years so we're gonna
have to pay more money to fill up the
cupboard bush in the summer of 2008 when
oil prices were really high did this big
speech and he said we are going to do
everything we can here in america to
drill domestically and the very next day
oil prices on the world market went down
ten dollars it was just on that speech
and that's what joe biden doesn't
understand you have to send a signal to
the producers in the market that we are
in there for the long term biden signal
to oil and gas is we're putting you out
of business and that's really bad for
business here's how stupid joe biden is
now that we're onto that subject you
can't just like hop from lillypad to
lillypad oh we have an energy crisis
we'll hop over to electric there's one
percent of the cars on the road that are
electric vehicles only 12
of our energy consumption is renewable
it's not that easy you can just flip it
over like that so
he needs to figure this out because as
you pointed out earlier in your question
this is a 5 000 a year tax hike on the
american people not just the rich you're
making minimum wage you're getting hit
with a 5 000
a year tax hike from joe biden okay and
you know
geraldo one of the problems is yeah did
i miss you yeah i kind of missed you but
i'm glad you're back thank you i'm sure
the viewers are glad to do that too
all right let's let's talk about the um
uh the the uh
the least lands that they have joe biden
is now talking about penalizing people
who have leases on some of the oil
reserves
because he says if they don't drill for
oil we're going to punish them use it or
lose it what's wrong with that what's
wrong with it is some of them don't have
roads to get to the lease so you build
the road that's why you get the lease
because unless someone else happens when
joe biden ran for office he said he
wanted to destroy the oil and gas
industry so they've got to get permits
i concede that this is the very worst
time
for democrats to go to their climate
advocates and cut down on the production
of hydrocarbons i think it's one of
those act timing is everything in life
and in politics so i think that i
concede that uh and also i have a rule
that the higher the price of gas the
lower the popularity of the president
there's an inverse relationship and and
now you're you're seeing the you know
the price gas going up the president's
popularity are is uh is sinking uh in
terms of what's going on with energy you
really need now to understand like the
strategic petroleum reserve
there's 1.4 billion barrels just in the
part that the government controls plus
another 3 billion barrels in there that
private the private sector controls so
when you're talking about a million a
million barrels a day
for 180 days that's a drop in the bucket
out of the strategic preserve a reserve
what they're trying to do is to spook
the oil traders so they stop speculating
because it's their speculation i
maintain even though the oil industry
gets us a free ride at this table very
often
i i maintain that they are manipulating
the price they are taking advantage of
the situation right now and they are
exacerbating it and to make the oil
companies like the victims is is absurd
all right there's more oil in your
mustache geraldo than there are in this
i don't usually i don't use oil we
should tap your muscles or in my hair
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else